hallo miteinander das ist q&d zu der
Reportage lebensrettende Stammzellen wie
ich zum Spender wurde sehr stark viel
mal für die viele schöne Feedbacks für
Kommentar und fügt Frage die erste Frage
ist von der Anna sie schreibt ich bin
ebenfalls im Register drin im Moment
weiß ich jedoch nicht wie ich reagieren
würde wenn das telefonkäme das ist
spenden kann was sind deine Tipps um
sich hier vorzubereiten ja gute Frage
ich selber bin ehrlich gesagt
vorbereitet sie auf das Telefon will mit
mir registrieren
ich glaube wichtig ist grundsätzlich
dass man sich schon wieder Registrierung
kann vorstellen dass man so spannend wir
machen dass man sich das verdient gut
überlegt aber über den wirklich spendet
entscheidet mir denn erst wenn das
Telefon den wirklich auch Hund und der
berüchtig berücksichtigen auch die
aktuelle Leben total anders sie als
Prinz
Familie Situationen hat oder was auch
immer also genau erstellen entscheidet
man das und muss ja auch wissen Chance
dass man wirklich jemals brauchen ist
wirklich sehr sehr clearme ist ein
Prozent oder
Promillebereich also es ist Frage muss
ich da drauf muss mehr oder besser
vorbereitet
mit dem Risiko tut man wirklich groß
vorbereitet Anna schreibt auch noch für
mich ist es ebenfalls ein Faktor wie der
Arbeitgeber damit umgehen würde findet
die Reportage übrigens super danke
ja natürlich ist das entscheidend ich
das Gefühl oder würde jetzt mal darauf
dass viele Arbeitgeber relativ Kulanz
sind will sie das über die Sache findet
und dann gibt es natürlich verschiedene
Optionen
beispielsweise
Urlaub oder wegen als Engagement
würde das Rote Kreuz übernehmen
interessiert hat oder beschäftigt ist
das Thema Anonymität oder Beziehung
spannender und Empfängerin will das ist
schon total anonym und ich würde für das
die Diskussion gern zur eine wo ja
produzieren der markus schrieb zu dem
Thema es wäre schön wenn beide Seiten
einverstanden wären vor einer
Stammzelltransplantation das Infos
ausgetauscht werden können über die
andere Person klar ist dass man beide
Parteien schützen will zum Beispiel wenn
das ganze erfolglos war mich würde es
aber trotzdem mehr motivieren auch zum
Spielen zu werden auf das antwortete
Alfred wäre total falsch plötzlich würde
der Spender vom Empfänger etwas erwarten
und das ist nicht gut der Empfänger ist
ja auch in einer Notsituation und kann
oder will nicht noch zuerst mit dem
Spender kommunizieren ja wie ist das
bedient
du irgendeine Art von Kontakt vor oder
während der spannend Wille ich glaube ja
interessant und meldet sich freuen
die Person
funktionieren aber
irgendwie empfangen wir noch ein
bisschen
schlechter Wirkung
ich glaube also
schön oder interessant dass man die
Person kennenlernt aber im Endeffekt
sagt man eben du bestehst ja auch in der
schwierigen Situation sie ich mein Mann
ist wahrscheinlich
mir das vorgestellt habe
auch noch so klar aber alles gut ist ich
glaube
aus dem Pfanne oder empfangen
in uns
und es gibt eigentlich
zurückgehen und einfach das dass das
einmal bei mir Stress ist
und nur
Hitler im Endeffekt dass wir verschmiere
Risiken als Chance wo so eine Begegnung
oder so einen Kontakt würde
auch sehr spannend
macht mir
selber zu dem profitieren und darum
also sieht man auch nicht erwarte dass
man irgendwie für das noch etwas also
bestimmte Personen
sympathisch oder nicht
ja im Kommentar von München das Thema
kontaktspender und Empfängerin
erschreckt mich würde interessieren ob
es beim einmaligen Brief Austausch
Regeln gibt und ob sie nur durch die
empfangene Person initiiert werden kann
ja es gibt Regler also grundsätzlich
gilt mit
Persönlichkeit also man darf nicht
identifizierbar sie damit
gewährleistet ist und zu fragen
hast so ein Brief geschrieben genau
[Musik]
irgendwie
Dankbarkeit aber ja ich weiß ich habe
eventuell
danke sagen
dass die Person wirklich gespannt ist
und ähm außerhalb zeigen
Englisch verfasst oder genau ich kann
einfach kaufen
cool danke vielmals Mia fragt warum
dürfen eigentlich Diabetiker psychisch
erkrankte und stark übergewichtige nicht
spenden ja das ist richtig es gibt
Ausschlusskriterien wieder Registrierung
150 Kilo und nicht schwer übergewichtig
sind der Grund für das ist gemäss
Risiko von der spannend also für das für
das spannende und viel spannender in und
darum dass es spannender Schutz nicht
möglich ist begrüße selber chronische
Krankheit und außerdem muss Empfängerin
oder Empfänger auf wo übertragbare
krankheitserie schon wieder hergestellt
denn der Prophet Mohammed schrieb Frage
finden Sie es wenn jemand aus religiösen
Gründen kein Blut spendet also zuerst
mal es geht um spannt vor
Blutstammzellen
aber grundsätzlich ist es freiwilligst
dass ich jedem Sinne eigentlich
entscheidet über das Mitmachen oder
nicht Michaela schrieb mehr sie für
deine spannend mir wird wundern wenn du
jetzt Spritze nicht
zaubert werden für Injektion dann wurde
ich ja wenn man sich als Schwangere
Injektion nicht kann selber gehen
vorstelle gibt's zum Beispiel im Spital
machen
oder eben auch dass man Spitex für das
engagiert
denn die alte schrieb ich hoffe dass die
Doku viele Menschen erreicht die noch
nicht registriert sind und die sich
davon überzeugen lassen oft kursieren
hierbei noch veraltete Vorstellungen
über das entnahmeverfahren und die Leute
sind davon abgeschreckt ja dem stimme
ich grundsätzlich zu ich kann die
Erfahrung auch gemacht ich spreche
gefühlt wird ein ist
das ist total falsch also gemacht wurde
und wird auch nicht zugemacht du hast
schon seine Mutter gemacht sondern ich
noch mag aber der Grund für das dass die
falsche vollständige kursiere dich
vielleicht dass es nur zweite Variante
gibt verstanden
und zwar direkt übers Knochenmark die
allerdings deutlich seltener nur 20% von
der Fälle Variante wird
Operation direkt aus dem Beckenknochen
wenn es mal recht ist Stammzellen
individuell das ist natürlich nur ein
einmaliges
erholen die Spandau nicht gemacht haben
die sogenannte Peripherie spannend sind
Prozess über mehrere Tage
schrieb ich würde auf keinen Fall
Spenden das zu Langzeitschäden kommen
kann also was er das schreibt stimmt nö
das gibt kein nachweisliche
langzeitschaden zu schwimmen das gar
nicht so durchführen also der Spender
Schutz statt immer der oberste still
wenn es noch wissen ich entscheide
warum das einfach nicht machen
[Musik]
ja ich würde normalspende ich finde es
mega gut die Sachen ich glaube man kann
mega Positives bewirken für andere und
ich hasse euch als Privileg die spannend
machen
wenn es nicht aber
ich finde es schaut halt wie kaum
freihältnis zu dem wo das kann nichts
wenn da damit
haben sie ja geh an dann ist das für
mich so viel mehr wert als ja dass ich
ein paar Tage
und vermisse Dich im Spital liegt oder
schlecht es sind auch nur essbar
Nachrichten mit persönlichen Geschichte
also der Popcorn schreibt ganz toll ich
habe selber 1997 Knochenmark bekommen
hatte Vereinigten Staaten mehr weiß ich
nicht es waren damals etwa 4 Millionen
registrierte Spinner weltweit alles Gute
danke auch Ihnen
stellvertreten also schon vor 25 Jahren
und der sagen wir anschrieb danke für
diese tolle Reportage es ist schön als
Patientin die spenderseite zu sehen das
Pflegepersonal und Ärzte machen eine
super Arbeit ich dürfte im Dezember 21
Stammzellen empfangen und bin unendlich
dankbar dafür meine Schwester hat sich
sofort bereit erklärt und das alles auf
sich genommen es ist ein unglaubliches
Gefühl weiterleben zu dürfen durch eine
Spende ja die Kommentare natürlich super
gefreut und berührt und hat mich auch
noch mal darin bestätigt dass das ein
coole Sache von
q&ay zu der Reportage wenn du mir Events
so die Themen und Reportagen denn
abonniert doch den Kanal